on this very fine day in our republic i
am happy to report that the fine
conservatives of wyoming have booted
america's leading rhino republican liz
cheney out of congress congress lady
chaney was absolutely destroyed at the
ballot box yesterday losing her primary
race by 37.4
points which is a wonderful beautiful
absolutely delightful
thing some people might think that i'm
being too harsh on liz cheney here they
will say
liz cheney look okay yeah she did some
stuff with the dems but she was right
about a lot of things that's true
they'll say liz cheney voted with the
republicans 90 even 95 percent of the
time
that's true
that's true of all the squishes
most of the time the squishes seem like
conservatives that's what makes them
useful tools for the liberal
establishment
court jesters in the kingdom of
liberalism most of the time they seem
like the real deal but no matter how
often these court jesters vote with us
at all the crucial moments when the vote
really counts when the fight gets really
hot they squish john mccain voted with
republicans most of the time he voted
with trump most of the time and he
absolutely hated trump
but when mccain had the chance to cast
the deciding vote to repeal obamacare a
vote that he had promised to make a
central plank of his campaign platform
guess what happened
he squished he voted with the democrats
same goes for liz cheney she has voted
with conservatives most of the time
but at the crucial moments
she squishes at the crucial moment in
2020
she endorses joe biden
she flies cover for nancy pelosi's
kangaroo court hearings about january
6th
there's nothing noble about it
the libs are trying to spin cheney's
disloyalty as somehow noble or dignified
there is nothing noble about endorsing
joe biden there is nothing noble about
supporting pelosi's kangaroo court there
is nothing noble about flying cover for
the party that advocates killing babies
and transiting the kids and destroying
our country nothing noble about that
some republicans in moderate districts
sometimes feel that they have to squish
to save their seats and while i might
not agree with that i at least
understand the political calculus
but liz cheney she represents
wyoming
soon to say represented wyoming
she doesn't need to squish on anything
the only pressure that she feels to
squish comes from her deranged hatred of
donald trump
and of his supporters and her wounded
pride
and the popular opinions of the dc swamp
which apparently had much more sway with
her than the desires of her constituents
in wyoming
let chaney's undignified and unnecessary
loss be a lesson let it underscore a
lesson
that i try to reiterate on this show as
often as i can
never
ever
ever
squish to the libs i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from poet comic one
who says i'm 70 immunosuppressed and
i've been through a nightmare of covid
four days of an occasionally runny nose
a tickle in my throat and one full day
of the blas
sir that sounds absolutely
horrifying
you're right we should have shut the
country down for two years over that
you're totally right i didn't i knew
about the occasionally runny nose and
sometimes the tickle in the throat i
didn't realize that people were getting
the blobs
not to put too fine a point on it i will
move on from spiking the football over
the liz cheney loss but there's one
point i've really gotta
hit here because you're gonna hear it
from the libs all day who have a strange
new respect for liz cheney who are
almost certainly gonna offer her a job
on the view it's kind of sad for that
lady alyssa farah alyssa farah is the
new fake republican on the view she's
the new fake conservative and she just
got the job but now liz cheney who is
the darling fake conservative she's
certainly going to get the job offer
within what five minutes 10 minutes now
that she's lost i guess she has to leave
congress officially first that won't
happen until january but if i were
alyssa farah if i were any of the other
fake conservatives on cnn or msnbc i'd
be looking over my shoulder
because you've got i don't know how much
job security you've got with liz cheney
back on the market but what this with
the libs and what even many of the
squishy republicans are going to say is
you know
you might not agree with liz cheney
but she showed dignity she
showed independence of thought
she is her own man or in this her own
woman in this case that's what they're
going to say and
what's so insidious about this argument
is that
in principle that would be a great thing
in principle we don't just want to be
partisan hacks this is actually a really
important point in in dante's divine
comedy my favorite poem dante you know
everyone knows about dante's inferno the
hell part of it which is very
interesting and titillating but then he
goes to purgatory and then he goes up to
heaven and when dante gets up to heaven
he meets his most illustrious ancestor
kacha guida
kachiguide was this uh crusader it's the
man from whom dante gets his family name
and so kaczykweed is giving dante
political advice and dante was a
politician too in addition to a poet and
he says listen dante politics is going
to be really bad for you
you're going to get stabbed in the back
your opponents even the people you're
with they're going to go crazy it's
going to give you all sorts of problems
and he's foreshadowing dante's political
exile from florence and he says it's
really really bad
he says don't worry about those people
the people who are giving you all this
grief in politics they're going to go to
hell okay
but if you want to protect your
honor if you want to protect yourself
the best way to do it is to be
a party of yourself
the italian it's a beautiful i love the
italian that sounds so beautiful
how beautiful that is and not only is
the language beautiful the
the idea is beautiful too
you don't want to just be some hack
republican or some hack democrat you can
ally with these people you know politics
is a team sport you've got to work with
people to get things done but you you
want to be your own man absolutely
that's not what liz cheney did
that's not what she did
it may have it would even if she had
done that it still would have been dumb
because of the content of what she was
doing she was turning on trump for a
bunch of stupid reasons
and she was giving up all the wonderful
wonderful political wins because of her
own wounded pride
and her own kind of swampiness
but at least it would be
more understandable even maybe more
honorable
than what she actually did she wasn't a
party of herself she wasn't a maverick
she wasn't a rogue she wasn't her own
person she just
for all intents and purposes became a
democrat she endorsed joe biden
she voted for a guy
who accepted a taxpayer taxpayer-funded
abortion on demand who's advocating
transing little kids
who is
wants to throw open the borders and has
thrown open the national borders of the
united states
to say nothing of his horrible economic
policies stupid foreign policy
she sided with him
she became the front man for nancy
pelosi's kangaroo court
she's not she is not some independent
thinker no she just stabbed her former
allies in the back
for very bad reasons and now she's out
of congress or soon will be out of
congress
and that is a wonderful thing
on the substance even beyond her own
behavior and the process and the ways in
which she conducted herself on the
substance she was wrong
bill crystal the uh you know former
editor of the weekly standard former
conservative
who's now i guess a kind of liberal
critic and gadfly of the trump
conservatives
he said in 2016 he said between the deep
state and the trump state i choose the
deep state and he has reiterated that
point since then
liz cheney
essentially made the same argument
and
i'll speak for myself i assume i'm
speaking for you here between the deep
state and the trump state i choose the
trump state meaning i choose
the
old american way of life the traditional
american order the will of the american
people over a bunch of unaccountable
unelected bureaucrats who are extremely
corrupt and left-wing
and every
single
time you see a showdown between the
trump state and the deep state the deep
state comes out looking even more
corrupt and trump comes out looking even
better
no matter what the media try to say
you're seeing this again now cbs just
got caught in a big lie flacking for the
deep state and unfairly attacking trump
nora o'donnell on cbs
after donald trump came out and said hey
the doj not the fbi not only did they
go through melania's closet not only did
they take a bunch of my documents not
only they raid my house an unprecedented
way they took my passports
norah o'donnell says new according to a
doj official the fbi is not in
possession of former president trump's
passports trump had accused the fbi of
stealing his three passports during the
search on his mar-a-lago home
uh-uh i just talked to the doj and they
told me they totally didn't do that
and then here's the second tweet when
she realized she probably got it wrong
she goes
we're also learning tonight that if any
item's not contained in the warrant were
retrieved during the fbi search at
mar-a-lago they will be returned
yeah they didn't do that they didn't
take any of that stuff but they'll give
it back
and then trump just publishes an email
from the doj acknowledging
that yeah they did take his passports
and what does cbs do what does nora
o'donnell do there it is
we've learned that the filter agent sees
three passports belonging to president
trump oopsie daisy we'll give him back
soon sorry
what does cbs do no deletion no
correction no apology
moving on moving on you you've got the
evidence of the corruption of the abuse
of the deceit of the deep state and the
media propagandists for them right in
front of you what do they do
never mind darn that that road runner
trump got away from us wiley coyotes
again all right that's okay we'll get
him next time never mind get me the next
acme anvil how do we get him again
and liz cheney and the rest of the
squishes they side with them
pathetic
absolutely disgraceful
you got to protect yourself we got to
protect our political party our
political movement our country and you
got to protect your home that's why you
got to check out ring right now go to
ring.com
knowles summer is very very busy it's
been especially busy for me i know
people go away from home on vacation i
was away from home at the hospital while
my wife gave birth to our second little
son and when i'm away from home i am so
pleased to trust
ring you know you know about ring
because it is a video doorbell where you
can see and speak to whoever is at your
door they've been with this show for
years almost since the very beginning we
love them it's a great product then
ring came out with the alarm ring alarm
is amazing you can protect from freeze
fire flood the bad guys keep an eye on
your your windows and your doors that's
all great did you know that you can go
pro
ring alarm pro will allow you to protect
not just your physical home but your
digital home as well cnet calls ring
alarm pro a giant leap for home security
it protects your data your digital home
with an eero
wi-fi 6 router it's absolutely fabulous
this summer season
to protect your home you got to go pro
be a pro just like me ring alarm pro
learn more at ring.com knowles that is
ring.com
knowles
the libs
will do
whatever they can to stop trump
not just the good honorable stuff
they're going to do very dishonorable
stuff very unjust stuff very illegal
stuff if you ask me anti-democratic
stuff
they might even rig an election i know
are you allowed to say that
they might even
say change all the voter rules and
encourage in particular widespread
mail-in voting
and extend election day to election
season to get a bunch of fraudulent
votes to rig an election are we allowed
to say that well you're allowed to say
that
even in los angeles even in a very
liberal city
on some issues
but not on others on some elections but
not on others when when saying it about
an election favors democrats you're
allowed to say you have to say it
when
making that point about election
integrity and fraud favors republicans
that's evil that's misinformation you're
a threat to our democracy but the libs
are doing it right now i mentioned this
yesterday there is an effort to recall
that george soros installed d.a george
gascon who has caused crime to skyrocket
in los angeles was already bad before
and now he's letting all the criminals
off the hook so there's an effort to
recall him after the successful effort
by the san francisco democrats to recall
the san francisco d.a who was so
left-wing jesus boudin that even the
dems in san francisco said we gotta get
rid of this guy
so there was a similar effort in la
and it just failed it's really weird
really weird because the
the petition campaign to recall this guy
required 566 000 or so votes
meaning signatures on the petition it's
not like they actually went to a ballot
box you had to go get the signatures
write your address 566 567 000.
the campaign got 715 000
and yet
they disqualified
200 000 of them
200 000 signatures so that means
that over 27 percent
of the signatures submitted on this
petition to recall george gascon were
deemed invalid
by los angeles county
guess what percentage of mail-in ballots
were deemed invalid in the 2020 election
right we're talking about basically the
same procedures here basically the same
requirements for both the petition to
recall the d.a and the mail-in ballots
in 2020. for the petition to recall the
liberal d.a 27 deemed invalid in the
2020 election
less than 1 percent
deemed invalid
how do you make sense of that
january 2021 the county reported less
than one percent of the three million
422 585 vote by mail ballots were
rejected the test for validity
is similar
the requirements for checking signatures
address is all similar what are the
freaking odds that's so weird
it's almost as if
they rig the rules
depending on what outcome they want
and now we're not are we even allowed to
say that
it's i keep bringing this point up
because it's such a good point by mike
anton at the claremont institute it's
the celebration parallax
the very same
situation
can be
celebrated
or denied
depending on
who the one is claiming it
who the one is that's claiming it when
that when the liberals say
that this sort of thing is happening
there's fraud with the mail ends with
the with the petitions
well that's we have to celebrate that
thank goodness we called all that fraud
thank goodness we still get our great
wonderful soros d.a george gascon to let
all the criminals off the hook
and then the republicans say the exact
same thing they say you know there's a
lot of fraud there are a lot of all
these problems a lot of these signatures
and ballots probably aren't invalid how
dare you you're a threat to our sacred
democracy the rule of law matters i
stand i stand for the rule of law that's
what liz cheney says i stand for the
rule of law i support the rule of law
and the democrats who burned the country
down for eight months and let all of
those criminals off the hook and locked
down all the rest of america except for
our terrorists that we let go out and
loot stores and burn countries and then
i support the party that bailed those
criminals out of prison
because the rioters had to go they had
to get back and ready in the game so
they could go try to kill a supreme
court justice for overruling roe v wade
because i support
oh gosh it brings a tear to my eye i
support
the rule of law
that's why we're going to change all the
election rules right before the election
in some cases in violation of the state
constitution because by golly if we
don't have that we don't have a country
so ridiculous
so
nothing honorable the rule of law give
me a break
and they all make it about january 6th
january 6 where there are a whole lot of
questions i mentioned that report
yesterday on the member block of this
show
from revolver news about all the strange
coincidences with the pipe bombs that
were allegedly planted the day before
the the evidence is not really adding up
the fbi is being really cagey not
releasing any information that they have
about it
so we already know there were some
suggestions that maybe there was a
federal
role in some of the events of that day
actually the the guy who was promoted to
be the head of the washington field
office for the fbi
in just the months before
january 6 and now who's in charge of the
investigation he's the same guy that led
the entrapment hoax
on the completely ridiculous
kidnapping plot for gretchen whitmer
turned out to be a totally bogus fed up
so that same guy after that op falls
apart he gets promoted to dc just really
it's really weird stuff
okay and they say but regardless of any
of that january 6th the horn hat guy
dancing around the capitol rotunda was
the worst insurrection ever wasn't the
worst insurrection of the year
the lm was the worst in sir antifa those
were the worst insurrections of the year
those actually killed people the only
person who was killed in the political
violence of january 6 was ashley babbitt
she was a trump supporter who was killed
by a trigger-happy cop
dozens of people were killed by blm
well that doesn't matter we're going to
side with that party mitt romney is
going to go marching with blm liz cheney
is going to go support the democrats
not honorable not honorable stuff folks
it's a really tough week for the
establishment media because
a lot of their narratives are collapsing
a lot of their facade of integrity is
collapsing speaking of violence and the
collapse of the media's veneer of
integrity
the new york times has just had to fire
one of its reporters
fired the reporter for um
praising hitler and calling for the
killing of jews
this reporter
reported by the name of fadi hanona
reporter in the gaza strip
said quote
the jews are the sons of dogs and i am
for killing them and burning them like
hitler did to them smiley face i would
be extremely happy smiley face
i tell you i don't accept a jew or an
israeli or a zionist or anyone else who
speaks hebrew i'm for killing them
wherever they are children
elderly soldiers i'm for killing the
jews wherever they are so says this uh
new york times reporter they just had to
fire
you know political correctness yet again
no i don't think so i'm all against i'm
against political correctness you know
and certain speech codes but i think
call me crazy i think
if you call for
indiscriminately killing all the jews
and the children and the elderly and the
women you shouldn't write for
major newspapers i think i think there
should be some standards there and yet
this guy
was contributing
to a number of new york times articles
whenever the libs attack us
for our
on the right they say we don't have
journalistic integrity we publish fake
news or whatever nonsense
i think well you know we don't
we don't hire these guys you know we
don't
i don't know of any
mainstream conservative reporters for
mainstream conservative news
organization they call for
indiscriminately killing all the jews
now that's the new york times that did
that
forget that for a second yeah i think if
you went and looked not on some stupid
liberal fact check site but actually
just kind of looked ch fact checked
yourself fact by fact
the conservative news outlets would have
a much better record for accuracy and
integrity
than
the left-wing outlets
is there even a question about that
anymore
after the new york times and the
washington post to say nothing of
buzzfeed and yahoo news carried water
just absolutely
planted the the fabricated information
that the democrats cooked up to to
launch the whole russia hoax in the
first place
followed by all of the fake news over
the years especially about trump
it's not even close you could look at
the average
right-wing blog being run out of
somebody's basement and compare that to
the new york times and the washington
post there'd be no question the right
wing blog would have much more integrity
and would be much more accurate i
promise you one thing the the right-wing
blog wouldn't be running its editorial
decisions by
u.s senators and politicians like the
new york times does according to barry
weiss across chuck schumer really tough
week
for the establishment media
you still giving your money to woke
razor companies that hate your values
and see manliness as toxic and think
that you should teach your daughter to
shave her beard
there's a better way
jeremy's racers 100 real 100 woke free
the premium matte tungsten handle has
more heft than the left i guess that's
not saying very much well what heft does
the left have the razor head pivots
without caving and has six blades that
are sharper than truth
those other razer companies keep virtue
signaling to the totalitarian left and
using your money to do it but you don't
have to let them when you buy jeremy's
razors you aren't just making jeremy
richer you're making the woke left
poorer 75 000 people have already made
the switch visit i hate harry's dot com
get your founders series shave kit today
i hate harry's harrys.com jeremy's
razors shut up and shave
whoever is writing our copy deserves a
promotion that's great that is great
advertising copy speaking of the jews
there is a controversy
right now
around genital mutilation and this is
coming from the left it's actually
coming from a guy who kind of sort of
calls himself a conservative even though
he's really more on the left andrew
sullivan
and it's a response to the conservatives
who say we should not trans the kids
transiting the kids is wrong we
shouldn't be
chopping up little kids genitals and
pumping them full of cross-sex hormones
and making little boys look like little
girls and andrew sullivan
raises an objection
he says i wonder how many people who
oppose child sex changes also oppose
circumcision
similar principle of the bodily
integrity of children especially their
sex organs
i've actually given speeches before
and people have raised this point with
me
even somewhat conservative people have
raised this point michael how can you be
against transiting the kids
if you have no problem with circumcision
and i see how this
could be confusing
if you are starting from the premises of
the liberals even if you think you're a
conservative like andrew sullivan or
some of the people who've asked me these
questions at speeches
the the way this is being framed is from
an essentially liberal perspective and
andrew sullivan admits it he says it's
the principle of the bodily integrity of
children and bodily integrity is a
phrase that means
autonomy
self-ownership
self-determination
and because you're not asking the little
babies do you want to have your foreskin
clipped this is violating their bodily
integrity
that's a liberal premise
i don't think that children have
bodily autonomy exactly when i
when i
tell my kid to go to bed and he whines
and screams and cries he says i don't
want to go to bed well that's too bad i
guess technically i'm violating his
bodily autonomy because he wants to stay
out and play with his toys and read
little books and i'm saying no sorry
buddy got to put on the sleep stack put
you in your crib
he and this is true that when my kid
doesn't want to eat
and i say finish your plate he says no i
don't want to eat then he said finish
your plate that's i guess that's
violating his bodily autonomy no the
issue with transiting the kids
is not that it violates their bodily
autonomy
the issue with transiting the kids is
that it violates a principle of reality
namely that boys can't really be girls
that's the problem when you when you
have your little kid get a haircut he
doesn't want to get a haircut you're
violating their bodily autonomy that's
not the issue
the issue is that you are violating a
principle of justice and virtue
the reason i say this is from a liberal
premise here
and the people who begin with that
liberal premise have a hard time
understanding this
is that
for the libs autonomy is everything
this is true you obviously see this with
the modern radical left-wing libs the
ones who say we need to be able to shut
up whoever we want and destroy our
bodies however we want do whatever drugs
we want it's my body my choice man
that's what the modern libs believe
even the classical liberals
really really value autonomy so i need
to be able to do whatever i want trade
whatever i want i don't don't you come
anywhere near me man don't you impose
your rules on me i don't have to listen
to anybody whether it's the law whether
it's tradition whether it's society i'm
going to do me i'm going to do whatever
i want but those are those are both just
liberal positions the conservative
values
autonomy to some degree but only as a
secondary matter of importance
for the conservative
and more important
priority would be virtue and justice the
higher political ends
the reason that transiting the kids is
wrong
is because it violates justice
and virtue and reality
circumcision does not violate any
principles of justice maybe you like
circumcision maybe you don't like
circumcision some people say it has some
health benefits
some people dispute those health
benefits some people say well you know
look it's got it's a custom that goes
back uh millennia
jesus was circumcised good enough for
jesus good enough for me okay and some
people say no we don't need to be
circumcised if you're a christian you
don't need to be circumcised for
religious reasons baptism takes the
place of the ceremonial circumcision but
regardless okay fine whatever you want
to say about circumcision it doesn't
violate any principle of reality it
doesn't pretend that a little boy is a
little girl
just clips a little little piece of the
foreskin
transiting the kids removing the the
womb of a little girl as the boston
children's hospital now does slicing off
the forearm skin
you want to talk about slicing off skin
the forearm skin and the calf skin
slicing off people's flesh off their
arms and legs to then create a fake
phallus on little girls that which is
actually happening right now
that violates justice and virtue and
reality principles of reality itself
that's what's wrong about it
conservatives fell into this trap a
little bit when it came to the vaccines
because in the beginning conservatives
ironically would say back to liberals
when the liberals said you know go get
the fouchy algae the conservatives would
say what happened to my body my choice
my body my choice i don't want to get
the vaccine but the reason that was
funny
the reason it's ironic to quote that
back to liberals is conservatives don't
actually believe that we don't actually
believe that you have the right to do
whatever you want with your body
whenever you want to do it
maybe some extreme libertarians believe
that conservatives certainly do not
that's why we support reasonable laws on
drugs that's why we support reasonable
restrictions on weird sex stuff and
marriage and stuff like that
not bodily autonomy libs speaking of
transgenderism
i mentioned a story a few weeks ago
about an 80 year old woman
who was banned from her community
swimming pool
because she complained that there were
dudes showering in the women's shower
getting changed in the women's locker
room in front of this woman uh so this
woman is still speaking out i mean you
would think if an 80 year old woman at
the community pool says hey get that man
out of my changing room oh my gosh this
creepy dude is with his
male genitals is looking at me here
naked get him you would think the pool
staff would come over and remove this
obviously disturbed mentally ill man
from the locker room no
because we live in clown world they kick
the old lady out pardon i don't mean to
say old lady lady of a certain age
no lady never tells her age this this
very uh articulate woman who had every
right to be in that
uh pool she is now speaking out she
comes out
and and she tells her harrowing story
and
the libs protest her
a naked old lady in the women's shower
room and what i saw that day
wendy bart ceo of the ymca told me
pride posters are adequate to let people
know women know what to expect
in the shower room known for 60 years as
a female only
one will now encounter men who identify
as women
undressing and showering with female
humans
i object
i don't want to be forced to shower
and dress with the opposite sex presence
right
[Applause]
which side are you on
those are the two sides
are you on the side of the lady
who wants to be able to shower without a
naked man leering at her
a nice 80 year old lady or are you on
the side of these screaming lunatics who
should be locked up in a straight jacket
in a padded cell because of how nuts
they are to say nothing about
disrespectfully they're asking it's
probably not even totally their fault
that they're behaving so bizarre in such
a bizarre way and so disrespectfully
they have
very serious psychiatric problems
and what's amazing about our clown world
that we're living in
is that
we're being told the person with the
problem is the 80 year old who wants to
shower without the crazy dude looking at
her
she's the she's the one with the problem
she's got to change her mind change her
attitude
the crazy people
who
the men the crazy men who bust into
women's locker rooms and stare at
80 year old women naked
they're no they're the ones who are
right we need to protect their right to
do that of course not which side are you
on
if you're listening to this show i have
a feeling i know which side you're on
that's a question that we've got to ask
liz cheney
chose the other side the squishes
and the libs
and the ex-republicans they chose the
other side
and they did so the argument was
this is this is liz cheney's entire
political calculus
stopping donald trump from being
president stopping people from electing
donald trump stopping donald trump this
horrible terrible crazy man
is worth
helping people to accomplish what those
lunatics were doing screaming at that 80
year old woman
it's worth transiting the kids
it's worth killing all the babies
it's worth burning down the country
blm and antifa and bailing him out of
jail
it's worth
trying to assassinate brett kavanaugh
and the supreme court justices it's
worth destroying our national borders
it's worth upending all of our election
laws destroying the faith in our
elections to stop
donald trump from what
from what from
changing our trade policy a little bit
make it more fair from getting nato
members to pay up a little bit more from
sort of slightly enforcing a little bit
of our border from getting some
conservative judges on the courts
that's worth it i don't think so i don't
think so which side
are you on
speaking of weird sex stuff
jeffrey toobin is leaving cnn
jeffrey toobin you may recall had to
take a brief leave of absence from cnn
after he was caught
how do i put this this is a family show
he was caught
being romantic with someone he loves
very much
to use a euphemism of woody allen he was
caught
uh
being romantic with himself
uh on a zoom call with his colleagues
and so he had to take a little break and
then they just led him right back i let
him cnn let him right back in so i know
bloom it was a really funny line neon
taster on twitter he just said jeffrey
dubin is quitting to spend more time
with himself
uh tuban's leaving he says friends i've
decided after 20 years i'm leaving cnn
after my vacation it was great to spend
my last day on air with pals wolf
anderson and don uh love all my former
colleagues watch for my next book coming
out from simon schuster okay
the lesson from jeffrey tubin here
is
you should not
do things that you would not want to
read about
you yourself doing in the new york times
that you would not want to see yourself
doing on television
i know this seems really basic this is
really basic like don't do bad do good
things don't do bad things but it's it's
important to remember because we forget
about it sometimes especially in liberal
modernity where we think that we have
the right to do any sort of bizarre
shameful disgraceful thing that we want
in private just can't do it in public
but we can do it in private and that's
not true you don't have a right to do
bad shameful things in private or in
public
norm macdonald had a whole great bid on
this
roxanna had a great bit about everything
but yes you don't have a right to do
those kind of shameful things in private
but also just as a technological matter
we're almost never in private anymore
we have surveillance devices
everywhere you carry a surveillance
device at least one everywhere you go
that's your phone your phone is
listening to you whether you're you're
actually using it with the screen on or
the screen's off or even the phone's off
it can be listening to you we've got
cameras everywhere in our society
surveillance cameras
in and we use it for security that's
just modern security now is we have
these cameras and it offers a lot of
benefits to us but then the other thing
you've got to consider is you're you're
always being listened to you're always
being watched
and we can complain about that it's got
some downsides to it one of the upsides
is don't do bad stuff it kind of holds
people a little bit more accountable you
don't want to do those things the other
reason to do it
is
we have a lonely and the other reason to
avoid doing bad things
not to do what jeffrey tuban did is
because
one of the chief
scourges in our country right now
is a loneliness epidemic you see this
crop up on social science survey after
social science survey
people are really really lonely it's
actually destroying the american life
expectancy it's decreasing now several
years in a row for the first time ever
because of deaths of despair because
people are killing themselves they're
doing drugs they're really they feel
isolated and they feel lonely and not to
be too scolding or sound like the church
lady but the thing that jeffrey tubin
did
and got caught doing
that a lot of people do
that is pretty much the loneliest action
you can possibly do
when you are
you know very involved with yourself
a man wrapped up in himself makes a
small package indeed it's the loneliest
thing you can possibly do because
our our bodies
are worth respecting
we're trying
it's weird in some ways we think that
we're just entirely our bodies and we're
bags of chemicals and we just poke and
prod ourselves and just try to get
whatever sense of pleasure we can but
then on the other hand in our society we
deny our bodies entirely we say body
doesn't mean anything
my true self is totally different from
my body that's why if i look like a boy
i can really be a girl because my body
doesn't matter
when we go between these two completely
schizophrenic ends
but we're both we're body and soul and
spirit and
the the body is a symbol
of our souls our souls are the
substantial form of our bodies
and so it means we've got to treat our
bodies with respect and our bodies have
natural longings okay the kind of
longings that jeffrey tubin was trying
to satisfy in a way that was not
particularly edifying and that it ended
up destroying his life
but our bodies have natural longings and
we're not supposed to
just deny them
we're not supposed to deny them or even
exactly suppress them i mentioned dante
at the top of the show it didn't even
occur to me to make this connection but
dante is
makes this point and it's such an
important point and it's a central
christian point
our our longings our erotic longings our
eros is good it's a gift from god and
we often abuse it to just bring us right
down into the gutter right down into the
sewer i read that story about you know
some guys gave their dog monkey pox
that's pretty that's pretty much the
most disgusting way you can possibly
direct your eros but eros isn't a bad
thing in and of itself and if you point
it in the right direction it will lead
you up it'll lead you straight up to
heaven that's what that's what the
divine comedy is about dante has an
erotic love for a woman named beatrice
and
even though he's he's not married to
beatrice he's only seen her twice or
something and he's only he's only really
met her twice and then she dies
at i don't know
in her teenage years he saw her when she
was nine years old falls in love and she
becomes this erotic image for him but
it's not just about her it's not just
about
stripping beatrice
it's his erotic love for her that guides
him up toward heaven he actually sees
god reflected in her eyes he's looking
at her but she's looking at god and he
sees that that's what we have to do we
have to take our natural longings
and not just turn them in on ourselves
and poke ourselves and pride ourselves
and take a bunch of drugs and stuff our
faces and doom scroll and just stare at
screens all day we've got to take those
natural longings which can be good and
guide them in the right direction or
else we're all going to become we're
going to do shameful things and then
we're going to be ashamed and we're
going to be embarrassed and you better
hope that you never get caught like
jeffrey toobin does on a zoom call but
why take the chance why do you think
jeffrey tube is happy
did he i don't think so i don't think
he's actually pleased himself all that
much speaking of putting hands where you
shouldn't
jo
man sometimes my segways impress even me
joe biden joe biden just caught doing
this joe biden was giving a speech on
his stupid inflation reduction act uh
joe biden uh walked up to the podium
i walked up to the lectern shakes
chuck schumer's hand he's got his mask
on because joe biden keeps testing
positive for covet and his wife who's
also got seven thousand shots she also
tested positive for cobin so he's got
his mask on shakes schumer's hand
and then shows you how silly the masks
are
[Applause]
he walks up with the mascot shakes you
over his hand immediately takes the mask
off and then just immediately coughs
into his hand
and then he grabs the podium
but joe biden does not know which end is
up this is not surprising at all joe
biden doesn't even know what his bill is
about because the bill is called the
inflation reduction act but but the bill
does nothing about inflation
even the the penn wharton budget model
says the bill if anything is going to
exacerbate inflation certainly in the
short run
and even bernie sanders says the bill
isn't going to do anything to stop
inflation
now the bill is being touted as a
climate bill
you know kind of green energy handouts
to the democrats friends and a health
care bill
and all sorts of goodies for democrat
priorities has nothing to do with
inflation
and if we had a an honest media in this
country if we had an honest press an
actual free press that that wasn't just
a bunch of propagandists for the libs
they would be calling them out on us
they say hold on you sold us a bill of
goods you told us that this three
quarters of a trillion dollar bill was
going to reduce inflation which is
something people actually care about now
we find out you're not even you're not
even referring to it as an inflation
bill anymore
you're calling it the climate bill
and the health care bill and then
whatever goodies we want bill
you lied to us democrats how dare you
know that what what did the media do the
media just completely go along with the
new script
and
believe it or not those media
and joe biden are actually coherent
compared to
the vice president
we know that we really are quite behind
in terms of maximizing our collective
understanding about how we will engage
on the technology of today
and what we can quickly and easily
predict will be the technology over the
next decades
so to maintain our position as the
united states of america on this issue
it is critical that we work together
to understand where we are
to recognize and have the courage to
speak truth about what is obsolete
and then to partner to ensure that we
are speaking the same language
with the same motivation
inspired
by the opportunity of it all
but then doing the work of updating
how we've been talking and thinking
about
our exploration in space
i defy you
to tell me
anything that she actually said there
any idea that she actually conveyed
or fact that she related
or anything other than a bunch of
meaningless buzzwords it sounds like a
seventh grader who didn't do the
homework and gets called on by the
teacher and we need to it's so incumbent
for all of us to come together like
every
incompetent employee
who or manager who has to hold a meeting
and you go into the meeting and they
start talk and you just have no idea
what you leave the meetings i don't even
know what that meeting was about
certainly don't know why it was called
people in all walks of life do this you
certainly see it in business
see in academia all the time you see it
in politics
some people have something to say
some people just like to hear themselves
talk
some politicians want to do something we
call them conviction politicians some
politicians just want to be
in an office
those are the convenience politicians
those are the opportunistic politicians
that's kamala harris and joe biden they
don't believe anything they have no idea
what they want they have no idea
biden more so than kamala maybe has some
thoughts though i really sincerely doubt
it neither of them really believe much
of anything and so it's no surprise when
they speak they just babble because
there's nothing they have nothing to
convey
they're just going to do whatever they
have to do or say whatever they have to
say to remain
the person who is in that office
on the flip side you get some conviction
politicians like our guy down in florida
ron desantis
they lied to us about the mrna shots
they said if you take it you will not
get coveted that is false that is not
true and they continue to say even now
when the evidence is so overwhelming uh
that not only is that not true people
that have multiple boosters you know
you're you're definitely at risk of
getting it there's no question about
that and then what happens is is that
they will say something like okay
six weeks of mass will end covid so
that's what they claim it doesn't happen
and then what they'll do is they will
kind of move the goal posts and say well
you know only 95 percent wore it so now
and they will constantly uh try to shift
because they will never admit that their
ideology was was incorrect so that's
very very dangerous when you're looking
at all these things so that's a problem
with our society that we're grappling
with and what i've said in the state of
florida because we've taken on woke
corporations we've taken on esg
obviously in the classroom we've battled
a lot of ideologies
but what i've said is that the state of
florida is the state is the place where
woke goes to die
love it brilliant line this guy is he's
like the opposite of kamala harris the
opposite of joe biden this guy has so
much disasters you libs were wrong about
this you were wrong about this about
this fact nope don't you're not going to
get away with it and about these numbers
and we knew it from the beginning and i
hate to say i told you so but that's how
it works and this pla
lest you be confused like some of the
libs they want to go into a room they
want they want everyone into in the room
to think that
they agree with them that the speaker
agrees with the people in the room even
if the people in the room disagree on
subjects they just want to glad hand and
backslap and simper and that's not the
santas he goes i want you to know
exactly what i think lest there be any
confusion florida is the place where
woke goes to die on this issue and that
issue and the other issue too we need
more of that
be that kind of politician don't be
the meaningless platitude buzzword
politician don't be the squish
politician don't be the prideful
politician the the just vindictive
personality game politician don't be the
rudderless politician don't be the
opportunistic politician of convenience
you act if you're gonna do anything in
politics you gotta know what you believe
or you will be swept away now the rest
of the show is going to continue now
you do not want to miss this if you are
not a member what's wrong with you what
are you doing come on man you got to
join this part of the show the member
block is not for the hoi polloi
it's for the members click on the link
in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]
you